the second day of the lattices theory to
practice workshop so we have four
wonderful talks today and let me first
say a few things for those of you who
were not here yesterday you can you can
ask questions we are the Q&A interface
that you see at the bottom of your
bottom top depending on which computer
you're using of your zoom screen and and
the session chair will you know will
work with the speaker to get these
questions answered either right away or
at the end of the talk you know
depending on what is most appropriate
and and and yeah so so so welcome to
everyone in case the zoom gets
disconnected hopefully it won't happen I
want to remind everyone that that the
talk is live streamed on YouTube from
the Simon's Institute web page so if you
go to the white page you can see if you
can stream it on YouTube is there
anything else that I wanted to say
that's that's about it so I'll hand over
to Adam who will lead the way yeah okay
thanks so I guess I will just hand it
off to Leo who is a researcher at CWI
and you'll talk about side-channel
attacks on lattices so thanks Lee
Thank You Verdun so before I go into the
technical talk I would like to share
with users the political victory of the
day in France so there was the fear by
different governments would pass low to
enact tracing Cova tracing app and it
would pass this law as a package with
all many other measures which should
have been a kind of a denial of
democracy this is a topic that deserve
debate democratic debate fortunately
this did not happen and this is maybe
because of
the actions and the political
involvement of many French khatola hell
that includes not limited to
uncontrolled them yesterday and/or
disability so I really want to thank
them for having been active on this
topic so that we have a proper
democratic debate I also want to invite
you to all be involved politically on
this topic and not just technically and
for this it means that you have to think
not only as a scientist but also as a
citizen and in particular as scientists
we can have two kind of biases either
you know we're doing cryptography we
privacy is very important in privacy of
medical data is very important therefore
we must not touch that it despite
putting other potential beneficial
aspect so I think we have to speak about
privacy but we have to be aware that it
is a trade-off between privacy and you
know other matters and we can speak on
privacy but it doesn't mean that we have
alone the knowledge to decide what is
the best trade-off but there's also the
other bias the technical bias maybe we
can be very excited to see cryptography
being deployed to get us out of this
crazy crisis
yeah be careful about this because again
you will lose your objectivity and you
might you know define a model and define
what anonymity means and prove that your
protocol is anonymous when you're still
kind of a lot of different kinds of
attack that still break this anonymity
so be careful about your own biased and
please be politically active contact
your local politicians you know watch
what is going on keep informed about
what is going on and try to inform the
general public using your knowledge and
only your knowledge which also said
let's go to the technical talk let's
talk about that this is and enjoy a
little bit of Matt
ethics is purely academics no more
politics I promised so yes my talk is
about it's not exactly about
side-channel attacks it's more about you
know what can we do with side-channel
information or not ECC side-channel
information but just side information on
an LW instance and how does that help to
to break an elderly instance in in a
very concrete sense so we're trying to
quantify very precisely and harness and
this is joint work with donna deokman
solid using gong and many servos okay so
here's here is a set up we have those
people there side channel cat analysist
and they have some fancy equipment they
do measurements on a chip and from those
measurement they think very hard they do
some computation and maybe they extract
a secret key if they gather enough
information from their measurements and
we have algorithmic cryptanalysis --tz--
what they do is they look at the public
key they think very hard do a lot of
maths
do a lot of computation sometimes
billions years of computation and then
they recover the secret key at least in
principle so the question that motivated
this work was the following let's assume
that we have side-channel catalysis that
mounted a physical attack on the scheme
and that extracted some data but despite
all his effort all his mathematics and
all this computation is not able to
recover the secret key out of it on the
other hand we have the the regular the
algorithmic cryptanalysis you know that
only looks at the public key and try to
recover the key from it the question is
can we recycled this information that
was not sufficient for a direct site
generator akka and feed it into the
usual lattice attacks so that maybe we
can decrease the cost of the center so
that we need less computation to perform
this attack
okay and basically this equation what
we're trying to do is to try to design a
framework where it is very natural to
start from an LW instance and to add
extra information on it and see what
happened on the lattice problems that
we're dealing with and by doing so we
don't only know attacks in the size
side-channel scenario setting we also
able to use and exploit information that
could come from different sources for
example from active attacks that has
been a topic of study especially on
these candidates if you can take a
decryption failures how how does it help
you and very adorn analysis have been
done with this I will also show that in
some specification of schemes that are
sought for the real world it is not
exactly your textbook lwe there will be
some tweaks that's been to maybe help
this or that aspect of the scheme and
that may be those things can be sold as
extra information that can also be used
to mount attacks so here I'm mentioning
especially and who like and round five
in in other sense but they've already
been accounted for in lizard and n3
prime there are also some tweaks that
are naturally included in our framework
but I also want to mention that while we
do so in principle that there's some
extra information we do not at all
you know effect in any non negligible
way the security of scheme it is merely
food for thought on you know what what
aspect of a design can have an influence
on the hardness of the underlying that
is problem so what does our framework
would like well let me first compare it
to the standard methodology to estimate
the hardness of crypto system
a cryptosystem - lettuce attack so
typically you start from a public key
and then maybe you can view it directly
as a bounded distance decoding instance
so busy in a lattice lambda with a
radius R but sometimes for all the
schemes you might have to do a little
bit of a dog massaging to really make
the problem look like a BDD instance and
then there is a trick called the Canon
embedding that kind of homogenized the
instance to make it look like a unique
SBB instance and this is typically what
we are going to fit - that is reduction
algorithm so supposed to change a little
bit this methodology and do as follows
so what we are going to do is to
generalize the bounded distance decoding
problem to a distorted version of it and
this this distortion that we included is
going to allow us to more naturally
adjust you know the definition of the
formal problem - - kind of the
real-world instance that will we're
faced with so for example here we don't
need to do the add up tricks we can
directly see those people akiza's
distorted the instances but more
importantly this distorted version will
allow us to include little by little
extra heads on the secret vectors that
we're looking for and that are going to
modify the parameters of bounded
decoding instances and then at some at
the end we are going to do a step to
transform it to unique as VB infinitive
lattice reduction and this is a very
general way of doing it at kind of
systematize both Canon embedding and all
the adopt tweaks that we
that were mentioned just before on this
slide so the other contribution of a
worker are as follows so not only we'd
provide a kind of formal framework but
we also implemented
you know this framework in sage in a way
that can that allows us to actually run
those attacks or to make predictions
about those attacks on a way we also
propose a refine way of estimating the
precise cost of the primer lattice
e'terica
so that applies a bit more general
reason the goal of this work and the
purpose of this is that without this
refined estimation we would see a lot of
variation between the predictions and
the experimental results so because we
want to test our prediction we we really
need to make our tradition I can for all
kind of phenomenon that are considered
negligible as syntactically but you know
might matter for small dimension because
this is in small dimension that we can
actually run experiments and also a
contribution are some kind of
systematization of knowledge about all
those quirks that you have to do to
mount the lattice attacking in
particular so I'm not going to go into
much detail there and to show that our
framework is you know reasonably useful
we show three application example and
the first one is exactly in the line of
the main goal of this work namely we had
the side panel act for which the data
was too weak to be completed namely the
first side channel attack of the vapor
of both settle from 2018 and we show
that indeed this information can
tremendously decrease the hardness of
the underlying lattice problem a second
example or decryption failure as I
already mentioned and here we're able to
visit the work of daughter
and the last example it is really minor
quantitatively but interesting at least
conceptually are this this little detail
in an two lakh and brown fine that
allows you to that you can be that can
be viewed as a hint with an or framework
okay so a quick overview so first I'm
going to define more formally this
distorted version of the bounded
distance decoding problem and explain
how we estimate its complete hardness
secondly I'm gonna details detail what
kind of hints are fit within our
framework that can be integrated into
distorted the bounded distance decoding
instances I will quickly review or sage
implementation and at last I will
enumerate very briefly each of our
application example so the bounded the
distorted bounded distance decoding
problem and it's concrete hardness so
here's a formal definition so the usual
bounded distance decoding problem is
given lattice and the target G you have
to find the unique secret lattice point
s that is close to T and you have the
promise that this point exists and that
it is unique another way more
geometrical view is to say you have to
find the point that is in the
intersection of a lattice and a ball
centered at T and of radius R and there
is a unique search point well the
distorted bounded distance decoding
version is simply a generalization of it
where we replace balls by general
ellipsoids so we're going to have
lattice lambda and mean or a center and
a covariance Sigma or essentially the
shape of an ellipsoid and we're going to
have to find the unit vector in lambda
that you know is posted ellipsoid and in
the
this you can write this as using an
ellipsoidal norm etc etc but
geometrically it's just find this point
in an intersection between the lattice
and an ellipsoid a certain
simplification that you know we make
along the paper is that we're not going
to be very regarding about actual
distributions and somehow we're going to
conflate all distribution of covariance
Sigma as being gaussians of covariance
Sigma so in particular you can either
think of the talk of the problem you
know your LW problem has been uniform in
an ellipsoid of portion over certain
covariance or maybe other weirder
distributions so we're kind of making
this simplification so it's not entirely
formal
you know one second so there are no
distributions just to understand again
there are no distributions in this
problem the problem that you can wonder
about how the instance was generated in
particular it's it's a problem with
promise
right so kind of X minus T has been
generated by someone who knows it and
you know you can either of chosen it as
a Gaussian or or as something else and
this is where the distribution is kind
of hidden one layer above which then you
view as you're giving a new name to this
problem but it seems to be just bounded
distance decoding ad and you could apply
the transformation associated to Sigma
you could apply it to lambda and mu and
just get a regular bounded distance
decoding that is exactly what I'm doing
in the next slide so the reason is that
we do want to
have this notion of a distorted variant
of it is that if each time you have a
distorted version you you rotate your
lattice then the hints will also have to
be distorted in this new basis to make
sense so we found it much more
convenient to leave the ambient space
and modified and at least while we are
integrating all our hint let me go back
to this picture because the hint there
kind of expressed in the original basis
of the space if we were to you know
renormalize or instance at each step
then it would be a mess to keep track of
everything so I found it more convenient
[Music]
it is more convenient but whether it
deserves a new name I mean there are
already so many luckiest problems plus I
think that DB DD may already have been
used for the decisional so I understand
why it is more convenient to keep track
of Sigma I think you could just call it
to be DD without changing okay that's an
interesting suggestion thank you okay so
as dinelli mentioned it's we can always
bring ourselves back to the case of
balls and this is something that we want
to do because lattice reduction
algorithm are typically designed for
balls I mean it's kind of all equivalent
but it's nicer to renormalize everything
to everything so basically you take the
inverse square root of your covariance
matrix and you multiply all your inputs
by it and then you end up with an
isotropic instance your lattice has been
distorted but now the covariance matrix
is simply the identity and your problem
is on the distance decoding problem and
here I even normalized it in terms of
scaling so that the radius is always
square root of the
can see here I don't know if you see my
mouse pointer do you yeah I do
okay so so we can always convert it back
to be the instance but so the question
is on what those hardness depends upon
and this beading instance in hardness is
going to grow with the dimension D and
it's going to decrease with the volume
of the risk a lattice volume of lambda
Prime and the volume of this fiscal
lattice is just the ratio between the
volume of the original lattice divided
by the square root determinant of Sigma
so what is nice is that if you want to
keep track of only the hardness of the
Institute's you don't necessarily to
keep you don't need to keep track of all
the parameters of your lattice of of
your covariance matrix all you need to
keep track of is the volume of the
lattice its dimension and the
determinant of the matrix Sigma it's
going to be very nice for implementing
predictions so yes I want you to remind
that this scaling is certainly not new
it's more you know in a 40
systematization and you find it in in a
dark form and ways for analysis of end
result and you know it also nicely
smooth out this question the one one
technical question inside the canons
embedding technique okay so now two
hardness estimation so we really did not
wanted to enter in the whole business of
costing as VP calls themselves because
like everyone has his own model so we
settled to measure hardness in this unit
that we call the Biggs which is
essentially the block size beta that is
needed inside bkz to break the crypto
system and if you really want to convert
it to good old bits of security
a rule of thumb would be that three
weeks is about equal to one bit of
security and if you want to go in
details about how to do this conversion
then you can choose about 20 different
models from this survey of Martin
Augustine so how do you determine this
better well you take your parameters so
we call that I've normalized the length
of the length does not appear any more
it all depends on the volume of this new
lattice and its dimension and basically
the the beta to be chosen is smallest
betas that satisfies this inequality and
I'm not giving you the I'm not giving
you the formula for Delta beta it
doesn't exactly matter to to this talk
just want to mention this methodology
and this is a kind of popular
methodology of using the gram-schmidt
assumption and then doing some kind of
intersect argument on the garnishment
vectors to decide that the algorithm
should win or not this is not a very
precise methodology especially in small
block sizes and this is annoying for
experiments so we kind of refined this
methodology and we used the bkz
simulators and instead of the to replace
the gsa and instead of using an
intersect argument we kind of made a
probabilistic analysis of when the
algorithm should find the shortest
effect and this lead to much more sense
so in black on this curve you see what
this is the error of the prediction
makes when the experimental beta is on
the x-axis and here on the y-axis you
see how much the prediction was wrong
and you see the G intersect method it
grossly overestimate it grossly
underestimate the cost of at least
attack first block sizes and then
slightly overestimated for large block
sizes whereas a probabilistic simulation
model seems to give very accurate result
in the all range again this is only
somewhat news because all the ideas that
are behind this you know you can find
them in the literature in different
forms especially
numeration with pruning okay so let's go
back to the stunt whole topic of this
work how do you formalize hints and how
do we integrate them into the distorted
version of the bounded distance decoding
so there are four kinds of hints that we
figured out how we can integrate into a
lattice instance the first one a perfect
linear hints so you're given the vector
V and you learn the inner product of
your secret vector as with the vector V
second violent is when you learn the
same thing but only modulo an integer
and this integer might not necessarily
be the model skew of your lwe scheme
that point for example there are some
interesting cases where this modulus is
actually two despite the cue of the
scheme being large
you also have approximate hints so it's
kind of like the first one but this time
you learn the inner product up to a
certain error and the last kind of hint
is a bit weirder it's not related to the
secret but only some information about
the lattice and I will explain it it's
enough
you
and those prediction I will make some
hidden assumption you you have to refer
to the paper but basically you have to
assume that the hints are not redundant
in some sense and then this you can
formalize as a notion of creativity from
vectors so for this talk because
homogenize ation is always painful I'm
going to assume that the hints are
already imagined is that is for each of
those hints the value L is simply equal
to zero okay so how does it work out
well if we learn new product s scalar V
equals zero how do we interpret this
geometrically well we learned that the
secrets lives in the space that is
orthogonal to the vector V so that's
what question if we took questions about
your previous slide yes one you know
there are reductions from you know lwe
to lwe with linear hence right are you
saying that these reductions are two non
tight so you have to analyze the problem
with hints directly is that is that what
you're saying
I suspect they're highly non Tydeus okay
okay I'm really not an expert I've taken
a look at this literature and what
appears to me is that I mean although
seduction they lose a logarithmic factor
in the dimension of the lattice and in
terms of concrete security that sounds
huge as we will see from you know the
best attack I could design with those
hints you know if you given a single
linear equation the security decrease by
three bits additively
so yes that makes sense
second question is which can you remind
me which lattice is lambda is that so
the is that the kernel of is the del Mui
lattice or the or the dual of it it is
lwe lattice I I've actually not defined
lwe and I've just told you we're
directly working on
because I thought I only had 30 minutes
like so so the day I guess my confusion
is it's not clear what we has to do with
the lwe secret rather we have to do it s
so Z is a parameter of the hint it's
kind of it's it's you know for example
if you mount a side channel attack and
you're targeting the first coordinates
of your secret the vector V simply going
to be the vector 1 0 0 0 0 right but but
I'm referring to your fourth bullet
which says short vector hints I mean so
this is just a vector V in lambda with
no relation to s right yes I'm gonna
come to it later on and you will see its
relevance I'm gonna I'm gonna have one
slight pair for each of those all right
ok so back to this guy so as I said if
we have the equation s V equals 0
we've just learned that the secret
belongs to a hyperplane orthogonal to V
so what we can do is simply intersect
the lattice with with the and you have
to change the covariance matrix
accordingly you have to condition it on
being on a hyperplane and here is an
explicit formula for that so the effect
on the hardness is very positive because
not only you've decreased volume the
dimension by 1 but also you increases
the volume of the lattice and increasing
the volume makes the problem easier and
and you increase it by by a factor that
depends on the length of the vector V
that's it's a bit subtlety to to figure
this out but if you do a two dimensional
lattice z2 you will quickly realize that
this is true that when you intersect
lattice the volume of interest exactly
lattice depends on on the lengths
the vector defining the orthogonal of
that span again it's all under some
creativity condition that I'm not
discussing here so now modular hints so
this time we only learn this equation as
scalar V is equal to 0 mod K and here
we're still in luck because the space of
the space of all the points that have
this that verifies this equality xcolor
v equals 0 mod K that still the lattice
and if we intersect two lattice we still
have a lattice so again we can easily
import this information inside our
lattice problem and that essentially
does not affect the covariance it's only
increase the volume of the lattice by a
factor K and again that makes it easier
so here this effect on the covariance
might you know there you might lose a
small epsilon in here it kind of depends
on the smoothness condition and again
I'm going to conveniently hide this
under the rug and refer to the type of
for it
a third kind of hint our approximate
hint so this time we're learning that s
scalar V is equal to 0 or more precisely
that air scar V is equal to e for an
unknown error that you know for
convenience we're going to ask you to be
golfin and of variance Sigma square I
wrote Sigma but this should be Sigma
square here and the nice things about
Gaussian is that if you take a Gaussian
distribution and take a measurement of
it with a Gaussian error and look at the
conditional distribution then the result
is still Gaussian except that it's
covariance matrix has changed and this
is again the formula to compute the new
covariance matrix and here again you can
convince yourself that this only makes
the covariance matrix decrease right
you're learning information so you're
narrowing the
where your error lies and finally short
vectors hints so here the question is
I'm given a vector that lives in my
lattice and it's short and what can I do
is it it's it's not that I necessarily
want to do it but I'm just discussing
what you can in what you can do with it
first and what you can do is it is
project the lattice orthogonal e to this
vector it's projecting orthogonal e not
intersecting and that makes quite a
difference so in this case a dimension
isn't going to decrease by one but the
volume is in fact going to increase so
this is a trade off this might or might
not be a hint you want to integrate so
why are those hints important
they're here to formalize trade off that
is already happening is the fit analysis
of lwe so enough when you're when you're
analyzing the harness of LD sometimes
you kind of have too much LW equations
and it seems that lattice algorithms are
better off by ignoring some of the lwe
samples and it turns out that if you
interpret geometrically what ignoring
those L debris sample means it precisely
means projecting ultimately to one of
the canonical direction and why is it
meaningful to do this well it is because
you have q vectors in in the lattices
underlying LD u instances because the
vector of Q 0 0 0 and 0 Q 0 the audio
there are all vectors of the lattice and
they're somehow philately short they
might be quite shorter that what you
typically get if you just turn lll on
the honda lattice so they kind of useful
information so you might wonder why do I
need to abstract away this trick well
the thing is that if I start integrating
other heads am I
to make those few vectors disappear and
then I need to find other vectors that
would look like for example vectors with
not one cubit two Q's inside this
construction so this is this is a nice
abstraction of an existing trick but
it's also necessary generalization
within four fours ago that we're
targeting okay so we are all done with
the fourth kind of hints that exist so
now let's check that what we what we
predict is actually happening so for
this we implemented a whole framework
item and actually into with sage and we
actually made three different
implementation of the same API one of
these kind of full fledge and keep track
of every information the lattice the
covariance is able to run the attack but
also to make prediction and then we have
faster version that are only able to do
prediction or even more restriction and
here's a code snippet so in yellow you
have kind of the output of the
interactive program so you see that you
know is just a few line of codes you can
you know start seeing how hints can
affect an early instance so now let the
prediction versus experiments and thanks
to our refined estimates we we were able
to have prediction that are actually
very very close to experiments not only
on the starting instances but also as we
keep increasing the number of hints
we're putting in the instance so here
for each for each example we've run two
kind of different dimensions of so
that's why you see two curves and each
time the red curve is very close to the
black curve so I think that least look
very good that if you look very closely
you see that the
kind of a small gap here so it seems
that there is you know a minor
phenomenon that we're fail with that
we're failing to understand I'm failing
to to fully capture in in our model but
I think that overall the prediction are
pretty good you're good but not perfect
okay so we have a framework it seems to
make sounds prediction so now the last
question is how useful it is and you
know when you see little kind of hints
that I'm giving you in the framework and
you're side-channel cryptanalyst you
might say but commonly hints are never
linear and you're right typically you do
not get linear hints but maybe if you
are a bit creative you can still extract
some kind of linear information about
something that is nonlinear and as my
example zero I will take the Hamming
weight which is kind of you know power
analysis 101 so let's assume that we
have melded with schemes and we know
from the design of the scheme that the
secret the secret coordinates are all
uniform between -5 and 5 and now I do my
pourer analysis and I target the first
coefficient in this power analysis and I
learned that this Hamming weight is 2 so
if I combine this knowledge with prior
knowledge on the secrets I can deduce
that the first coordinate is either 3 or
5 because in this range minus 5 5 this
is the only integer whose your computer
representation has Hamming weight to and
from there you can deduce two hints the
first one is that the secret is odd okay
so you can write that is first component
is congruent to one modulo two and the
second hint that you can say is that it
is kind of close to four okay and more
precisely that it is approximately equal
to four up to a variance of up to an
ephah of fermions
one
okay so this is still a toy example I'm
not saying that this is realistic but
here I'm showing the principle that's
it's not because the leak is not linear
that you cannot extract some reading or
information so a more substantial
example that I'm not going to go into
details you have to go to the paper is a
more realistic example where we took one
of the two single trace attack that was
done by boss at Allen's father Kim and
all of those two attack there was two of
them there was a first one for which
data was leaked but the data was not
powerful enough for key reconstruction
and then there was a second league for
which a full attack was possible so I
really don't want to claim a new side
channel attack I'm really taking the
first failed attack as our perfect use
case as an example because this is the
whole principle of our framework is to
say when side channel attack fails what
can you still do with it so this is why
we choose this or your case and not the
more powerful side channel attack and
indeed we plugged all this in our
framework design the right hints and
we're able to see significant decrease
in security for example for the CCS two
parameter we can go from for more than
400 bigs to about a hundred peeks you
might not hear that I have like two
different attacks so the thing is that
we formalize things using approximate
hints but sometimes there's like the
data is very precise and you know with
99% confidence that this coordinate is
exactly this value and in that case it
might be better off to try to make a
guess that has a one person failure
probability and make you know maybe 50
such cases so that your success
probability still of 1/2 and Nuveen
great
and perfect things are very good for for
making the two problem easier
quick remarks is that the approximate
hints of
cursing the talker no exactly in the
form that we use here here we need to
directly given the posterior
distribution and the second remark is
that those number are not exactly
definitive because we've been told that
we're probably not using the data in an
optimal way so we're currently updating
and see how far we can push this my
second example our decryption failures
so this was a topic that was studied
it's quite a bit especially because of
miss candidate and the question is you
know in the design of those new schemes
you might not want to make the failure
probability extremely small or even
equal to zero because that kind of
affect the efficiency of your scheme but
the question is how how much failure
probability you can tolerate and if the
failure probability is is too large then
you're somewhat susceptible to this kind
of attack basically the attacker kind of
brute force through a random Oracle some
W and he queries with this W inside the
ciphertext noise decryption queries and
the decryption failure is going to be
triggered whenever this inequality
happens so s color W is greater than 80
so our first attempt to model this using
using or or hint formalism was to say
well you know when we've chosen W the
distribution let's assume that s is kind
of Gaussian and because decryption
failures are are very rare it's mean
that you know this we are in the very we
are really in the tail of the Gaussian
distribution forces inner product as W
and if we are in the tail of this
distribution the distribution decrease
extremely fast so actually knowing that
s W is greater than T is kind of like
learning that s W is very close to G
turn out that this reasoning is kind of
wrong because the hints are designed in
the other way around we first choose a W
and then we kind of query a leak on W
and then you know we learned something
here's the probabilistic experiment is
different we trigger we randomized a lot
W until something happens with respect
to s and that makes this W not
independent of s so actually it carries
much more information and you can
analyze it that you can actually have a
full dimensional hint actually all the
directions of W tell you information
about all the directions of s so for
each basically for each such W you get
not one linear approximate int but n
such ends and with this with this
analysis we were born in a rather simple
way of reproducing some prediction that
have been made by the other data and you
know I think that this method is
significantly simpler that was we've not
gained anything on the attack but I
think conceptually cleaner and okay the
last third example is quantitatively it
is kind of ridiculous it is really
marginal what it does on those schemes
but still conceptually I think it's it's
cute so on all those schemes in and who
like and round five for you know
optimization of the practical design
purposes they've chose the secret
underlying the LPO instances to be
ternary and have a fixed amount of minus
ones and ones and this you can write
directly as a perfect hint and that
directly translates into our framework
and here you need to be careful that it
does not only affect the dimension of
your lattice it also affected volume in
fact this hint is going to increase the
volume
factor square root of D and you know
some dispersion of this kind of happened
previously in the literature but the
effect on the volume might not have been
considered so again the practical impact
is ridiculous who knows maybe one bit of
security on all those schemes but he
also triggered some interesting
discussion with John shank and in
particular the attack of may and silver
man on exploiting symmetry so we're kind
of updating our paper to include more
interesting discussions on on this
particular point and that's pretty much
it I also want to thank all the people
we've interacted with you know to make
this happen will people the church code
or give us nice feedback or draft thank
you very much I will be happy to answer
any question you might have thanks leo
are there any questions we have some
time okay they had a question in
correlation between contribution vector
and efficient recovery attack on a lyric
I was wondering if you can use this type
of this is an interesting question and
fair question
actually we've looked at the literature
and there's like a dozen of potential
cases where our framework could be
applied to clean up or improve existing
work we we chose to limit ourselves to
only three examples but I obviously
encourage you to to try and see whether
this can be helpful for cleaning up all
the works I want to ask you this looks
great a nice talk so how much of these
[Music]
you istic to estimate the security of
assistance or is there some partner that
could be
described as an algorithmic result you
know if your etiquette result is there a
way to extract some type of theorem from
this I have no clue I wouldn't know how
to approach it honestly I think it would
be great if because basically this is a
work about upper bounds right it would
be great if this approach could also
lead to to to lower bounds I I honestly
have no no idea on the topic at the
moment another question you know you had
a little leakage linear leakage on the
secret lwe secret right how could the
secret and the error or maybe even just
the arrow you know there's been some
confusion what I call the secret here is
all the secrets that so both in the in
short secret form and what I call the
secret is both think you're thinking
about the knapsack form of interview yes
it's actually interesting so one quick
comment is that you know this actually
comes you know leakages more than
tripling here actually come up in the
over the reals they actually come up in
the in program obfuscation and they are
actually quite fundamental in the in the
embedded you you know you can prove
security of these you know they did it
so let's say take the lwe secret
concatenate the error vector and the
leakage is a degree two polynomial so
degree three polynomial on this and now
what happens is a pretty important
person maybe Rachel who is maybe here
can say well yeah I mean the the
framework we proposed is really on the
concrete side of things not really can
extract any asymptotic result on it
maybe you can I mean in all cases it
would be pretty heuristic that might be
sufficient
I don't know where the standards are on
this actually actually even if you can
break the assumptions that these people
make you know that that's that's a
concrete you know cryptanalysis question
you know I'll let other people ask
questions so maybe you can read out the
questions because as they said yesterday
the YouTube video will not see the
questions so if you could read the
second question and just answer it or
okay so I will answer so there's a
question from Fernando who say that with
a ratio of three weeks to one bit maybe
we can actually break in practice the
photos yes two parameters because it has
only 100 bits of security after analysis
so running bkz with block size 110
that's that's somewhat doable now
actually the difficulty is not so much
dkz but just managing the very large
matrix and restraining the initial lll
on it so it's kind of this weird state
where we know it's computationally
feasible but we just just don't have the
software to manage this easily
unless maybe Apple Kershner make is
awesome parallel ll open source so now
can you say bit more about the form of
the photo came leakage from which
significantly improved the attack it may
be a bit too technical
yeah so okay maybe let me answer the
question of Medi so so the leakage that
they give with what we try to use is the
score table that they gave in their
paper and so it kind of looked at the
most the best score and tried the juice
information from there
apparently this score table can be
interpreted either as a likelihood table
or as an a posteriori table and if we do
this we can improve the attack maybe a
little bit further so that's what we are
working currently and I think the
estimate the security evaluated by bigs
seems very different from the result in
the paper
estimate also build ability into schemes
what's the reason
I'm not sure this is the case for what
I've checked the prediction in terms of
the block size are pretty similar maybe
if you find some stuff that do not line
you can send me an email with with the
precise with the precision with the
precise example where there is a big
mismatch Leo won one more question
hi this is Chris yes it is I so it seems
like it's pretty central to the approach
in your framework that the secret or the
the BDD error be Gaussian distributed
with some covariance
can you say a little bit about how well
that assumption translates or doesn't
translate or can you do something in a
world where you know that the secret is
more like say uniform over you know 0
plus minus 1 or or something like that
where it's very much non Gaussian
no I I mean it's like you know
distribution can be very weird and
everything can go very wrong if you
designed you know a special-purpose
counterexample I don't think with the
natural distribution that we see in the
literature I don't think that this
assumption is making a huge difference
you know maybe some quirks could be
useful so what would break down in the
analysis would be the formulas on how
the covariance matrix evolved as you
integrate ends if you try to do it for
general distribution then it just
explodes to your face you know there's
just no way of efficiently representing
given this this information on the
computer so here it's kind of like I'm
it's it's frustrating but I don't think
we this approach has much more to offer
you kind of have to assume that
everything behaves kind of like a Goshen
and I guess thanks and I guess the same
answer for things where like the error
is is generated using rounding instead
of random error right yeah that's a good
question or I mean I mean for a concrete
design from running we're really far
away from the approvable range and I'm
always tempted to believe that you
something much more clever can be done
they're still not found what could this
framework help you know maybe you can
write some extra information as a hint i
i've tried and not been very successful
but sure keep keep on trying yes that's
the great thanks take the rest of the
questions offline surely we'll be able
to answer them email offline
let's set up maybe Katherine can set up
slides
thanks leo that was a great talk
[Applause]